Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo asmr ero in treno ragazzi
in Giappone non si parla in treno e
quindi per non disturbare gli altri ho
fatto questa intro molto dopo però stavo
giocando a Zelda quindi Ok ed è così che
si apre questo magico video
con questo taxi al centrino di mia nonna
come sedile Addio centrino mobile è
proprio il carro dei morti esercizio zio
bravo alleniamoci con lo Swing che il
golf è importante ma è più importante il
Qui dice Ragazzi Mamma mia Mamma mia
quanti video vi ho fatto del Giappone
possibile che c'è sempre qualcosa da far
vedere sì prossimo video ehm sui
cassonetti stiamo per vivere
un'esperienza a dir poco leggendaria
anche perché questo penso sia il parco
più ambito
Anche meno Anche meno eccitazione
Ma cos'è farei tutto
Scusatemi ed emozione perché lo devi
riprendere tutto nel minimo dettaglio
l'entrata appunto sto dicendo così che
voi possiate vivere una reale Experience
di quello che significhi
Allora ragazzi Adesso sto per entrare
fammi vivere al 100% quello che si prova
ad entrare qua dentro scrivetevi con me
in prima persona questa Experience
partiamo dal fatto che siamo dentro il
tubo verde di Mario che hanno messo in
orizzontale per ovvie motivazioni di
Confort Nel senso che entrare in quello
verticale sarebbe stato un problema
eh babbo
[Musica]
no raga sto sognando tutto quello che
vedete là è a grandezza naturale Cioè
nel senso cioè non so se si percepisce
dal video Ma se io andassi là sopra
sarei alto quanto Mario Dimmi che
qualcuno l'ha fatto sto percorso perché
è proprio grosso Ti muove tutto e di
questo posto è vivo
di carta esiste e questo è il castello
di Bowser credo che la prima attrazione
che andremo a fare Sarà Mario Kart coppa
Challenge 70 minuti di waytime noi
abbiamo il fastpass che ho già finito
Zelda quindi dai tutti avete iniziato ma
io sono stato più bravo quindi mandato
il Fast pass
Salve Salve buongiorno buongiorno giorno
giorno Giovanna giorno Giovanna
[Musica]
perché prima di entrare nel castello di
Bowser non si può non parlare di browser
ovviamente che tutti cambiamo Bowser per
browser che fate Lo so E di quale
browser parliamo Se non di quello più
aggiornato quello più chic quello più
incredibile e parliamo di Opera che io
usavo tantissimo ve lo giuro Ragazzi io
però l'ho sempre usato un sacco
soprattutto quando ero piccolo mi
piaceva un sacco non so esteticamente
c'ha quel qualcosa ma adesso c'è una
motivazione nuova c'è opera One cos'è
opera One come vedete è Cioè
praticamente si apre che sembra che è un
film cos'è che sto aprendo Netflix è
molto semplice intuitivo è bello
graficamente male cose che io preferisco
in assoluto ovviamente sono le icone
nella barra laterale
Vabbè c'è persino chat GPT Ma parlando
di ai ragazzi c'è una cosa incredibile
Perché all'interno di Opera c'è anche
aria e l'intelligenza artificiale di
Opera che direttamente integrata in
opera One e fa un sacco di cose può
tradurre può spiegarvi brevemente le
cose può fare ricerche ed è già tutto
all'interno del browser potete
disattivare l'attivare le vostre
piacimento Ma mica è l'unica feature
ragazzi è pieno di features si possono
guardare i video in background durante
la navigazione anche quelli del
sottoscritto signor Favij Quindi anche
tutti i video di YouTube e si può
migliorarne la qualità con la modalità
lucid Mode tipo questo video potreste
guardarlo con dei colori incredibili con
il mondo e se lavorate o studiare
Insomma con il computer le schede
possono essere facilmente organizzate
con workspace Si possono salvare i
contenuti web e condividerli con Pinball
potete passare i dati dal vostro vecchio
browser al nuovo browser con una
sincronizzazione dati molto efficiente e
immediata quindi non c'è neanche bisogno
che li riportiate a mano tutti quanti e
con opera wallpapers potete mettere un
sacco di sfondi fighissimi Insomma
ragazzi il browser per eccellenza lo
potete trovare qua sotto in descrizione
detto questo possiamo tornare nel
castello di Bowser che è molto tetro Ma
non avete ancora visto niente Ragazzi
abbiamo un vogg di premi vinti quello di
Valentino Rossi me lo ricordo Keep out
Keep out non esagerando ce ne accorgiamo
Ciao ragazzi Noi entriamo Eh ce ne
fottiamo Ok ok
ci ha mandato questo che è un cappello
di ma aspetta un attimo che questo me lo
devo mettere Ah ah ah
ok La stanza successiva è quel giorno
giorno
stanza dove ti puoi mettere le tute di
Super Mario Yoshi Todd terapia secondo
me noi non abbiamo la tuta chi se ne
frega facciamolo lo stesso Ok alla fine
di tutta sta mega pila che ha scritto
una fotografia per vedere i ricordi
Quindi
Ragazzi ci sono veramente i kart adesso
saliamo e vediamo allora ragazzi Jo
consiste nel vedere attraverso questi
occhiali la realtà aumentata e colpire
le cose come in realtà aumentata non ha
senso fare il video perché non vedete
una sega però aspetta vediamo se si vede
attraverso il coso è un po' un po' si
vede eh compaiono cose attraverso
non si può fare che non è godibile senza
la realtà aumentata quindi immaginatevi
che sto vedendo cose strane ragazzi
Io sto vedendo delle cose attraverso i
miei occhiali va bene Raga il mio
peggior incubo No
io che devo riprendere la patente
abbiamo vinto non so come perché la metà
del tempo l'ho passata a riprendere però
va bene Ed eccoci qua ragazzi siamo
fuori il prossimo che facciamo è Yoshi's
Adventures Sì sì arrivo signor ti
presenta subito con queste uova sobria
rispetto al resto sobrio Oh e arriviamo
alla all'attrazione con dei gigayoshi
sono tutte attrazioni un po' difficili
da far vedere in camera se ci pensate
perché è più il panorama occhio Ah cioè
abbiamo una visuale Non è vero
che dici pauser Fa schifo Comunque ah
siamo No vabbè siamo succoso Raga siamo
sul
sulla collina quella No vabbè ma è è
infinito Questo posto non finisce mai
vabbè ma chissà un cappello Qualcuno ha
perso il cappello posso prenderlo io
arrivo a prendere il cappello lo vince
Non è vero non ci arrivo ah
[Musica]
ho vinto un gioco
Oh mio Dio e hanno fatto tutti i propri
nemici del cioè tutti tutti i
mostriciattoli di Super Mario però
sembro io ragazzi dopo un bicchiere di
birra come sono io dopo che ho guardato
la birra quello non sono io perché sono
single
Comunque ragazzi siamo fuori Ragazzi
questa qua è la parte parte sotto perché
noi L'entrata del Super Nintendo World è
lì e non per questo è fatta male anzi è
incredibile anche qua tra l'altro Questa
è One up facto rientriamo e vediamo cosa
c'è adesso sia uno Store quindi comprerò
qualsiasi cosa vedo perché mi interessa
ovviamente tutto questa cosa è
bellissima e quindi ragazzi non possono
comprarla Ma quando non ho visto neanche
il prezzo Anzi lo scoprirò mentre la
comprerò e piangerò costato €25 eh vendo
vendo si ritrova solo al Super Nintendo
World quindi prezzo di partenza
€500 umile umile e c'è anche il Super
Mario Motors di Mario Kart Praticamente
sono tutte le cose in vendita di Mario
Kart compresi ehm i trofei che senza che
comprarli io non li vinco Mamma mia
Mannaggia che guancia Questi non sono
così questo quelli che lavorano li stavo
comprando pure l'orca e Mario sul kart
Eh va bene
ci sono anche non lo so perché in
Giappone vanno pazzi per
mettere le cose in testa Cioè voi vedete
in Giappone e tutti hanno le cose in
testa lei sta facendo da zio nubilato
Ottimo posto per farlo vedi si mette
potete in Giappone Mania il miglior
addio al nubilato della storia ragazzi
al Super Nintendo World queste cose Raga
ma che cacchio sono cioè tu da qua vedi
le cose no vedo solo Mary riflesso Oddio
Oddio
cosa che vola magari
sto male
in post praticamente la realtà aumentata
fighissima
Mario tifo per favore mi saluti mi
saluti in un video di Happy Grazie
pazzesca assolutamente
quindi ragazzi Questo era il Super
Nintendo World proprio
c'è una roba sobria molto scenico
Diciamo che più scenico che altro però
comunque l'attrazione anche sono carine
per quanto siano per tutti cioè non sono
il roller coaster quelli ci sono nel
parco normale Ah è ultimo ma non per
importanza Questa era l'entrata che
ovviamente sono entrato sono stato
ammaliato Da quello che ho visto
all'entrata Però effettivamente
l'entrata medica una ripresa a sé perché
siamo usciti da questo affare noi
all'inizio volendo si possono fare le
foto con pitch
ma io la cercherò su Tinder cosa vi
posso dire è uno di quei posti che nella
vita
ha visitato perché ve lo giuro
incredibile Spero che vi sia piaciuto
questo Trip al Super Nintendo World so
se ne apriranno altri Spero di sì perché
spero riusciranno ad aprirne uno in
Europa Però in realtà in Europa non ci
sono proprio gli Universal Studios
quindi dovrebbero prima fare il diverso
Studios e poi fare il Super Nintendo
World all'interno e non so quando perché
oggi c'è una giornata della Madonna non
so se tu entri all'interno World hanno
pagato il meteo hanno una licence Per
far sì che sia sempre senza nuvole però
la giornata si prestava anche molto
vedete il cielo Sembra finto totalmente
bello Comunque questo era il video di
oggi Spero vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
iscrivetevi al canale lasciate un bel
commento e un mi piace come sempre ci
vediamo ad un prossimo video
Vabbè è la chiusa cringe la dovevo fare